[Música]
es que todos los 31 de marzo se celebra
el día internacional de la visibilidad
trans con el propósito de reconocer la
lucha que han liberado estas personas
para que se les reconozcan todos sus
derechos la fecha busca generar
conciencia y reflexionar sobre las
condiciones de vida de estas personas
trans quienes enfrentan diariamente
también como lo hablábamos con más
romeros situaciones de vulneración de
todos sus derechos estigmatización
discriminación violencia y crímenes de
odio a causa solamente de su identidad
de género el término transgénero se
refiere a las personas que se
identifican con un tipo de conducta
sexual que no corresponde al sexo que se
les asignó al momento en la salle por
ello entonces quiero saludar a nuestro
primer invitado del día el es marc durán
él es el primer colombiano con cédula
trans en el país mal que gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 la verdad es un gusto que
estés aquí con nosotros feliz mañana del
jueves
buenos días cómo estaban muchísimas
gracias por la invitación mayo le
pregunto cómo vivir en un país
latinoamericano siendo una persona
transgénero cómo es aceptado en la
sociedad que ha tenido que vivir usted
desde su experiencia es algo complicado
es algo complicado como ustedes muy bien
lo hablaban es algo difícil acceder a
las hormonas por la dps ya que falta de
conocimiento de los especialistas que
llega hasta el punto de que nosotros les
tenemos que explicar cómo se lleva este
proceso entonces desde ahí empiezan las
trabas ya cuando uno quiere empezar un
tratamiento hormonal obviamente esto es
un tratamiento
que sí o sí es mejor llevar por la dps
porque tiene muchas alteraciones para tu
salud entonces en algunos casos las
personas se niegan a hacer esto por la
falta de conocimiento por el respeto de
los profesionales entonces el área de la
salud es algo complicado igualmente para
el cambio del nombre ponen muchos
problemas aquí en colombia de que no
tienen la misma información todas las
entidades
y te ponen a voltear y hacer cosas que
al final se pueden solucionar en un
momentico ósea
personalmente en mi caso yo soy de
bogota vivo en medellín y para poder
hacer el cambio tuve que viajar a bogotá
para que me dieran el registro civil y
así poder hacer el cambio sabiendo que
aquí en medellín yo podía solicitar ese
registro civil entonces por falta de
conocimiento de los de los encargados
nos ponen a nosotros a voltear y llega
el momento en que por eso muchas
personas desisten en hacer esto porque
se siente mucha discriminación claro
también lo decía usted mike en el ámbito
de la salud de recordamos para nuestra
audiencia internacional una dps es por
digamos donde se gestiona el sistema de
salud público de colombiano por qué pasa
esto con los especialistas en este
sistema de salud público en colombia que
a lo mejor ustedes pueden
proporcionarle al gobierno o que digamos
pelean en su lucha para que esto cambie
para que haya más información y más
acompañamiento por parte de los
profesionales de la salud porque al
final con ellos tienen que quedar así
ustedes y todos digamos y si ellos no
están bien preparados pues que queda
para todos
si es que es complicado porque digamos
tengo personitas que hasta ahorita están
iniciando el proceso y me escriben y me
dicen venga que lo que tengo que decirle
al especialista ya empecé y me dice que
eso no lo cubre la dps entonces no hay
una forma correcta de decirles a la
gente así es que se hace el proceso
entonces yo digo que también aquí
lastimosamente se mete la religión
porque hay algunos médicos que son muy
religiosos entonces como esto no lo
aprueba la religión entonces ellos
tampoco entonces aquí es donde nosotros
siempre le pedimos al estado como que
hagan más capacitaciones como que
instruyan a la gente y los profesionales
tengan conocimiento de cómo se lleva
este proceso para así sea más fácil para
nosotros o para los que vienen a acceder
a las hormonas por ejemplo para yo poder
iniciar tuve que colocar un derecho de
petición
porque según ellos esto no lo cubría
como ustedes muy bien dijieron hasta que
usted no tenga un diagnóstico de
psicología de psiquiatría no no puedes
acceder a las hormonas entonces es algo
frustrante para muchos chicos trans
aquí en colombia para solicitar una cita
con un especialista
por ejemplo yo que me toca cada tres
meses y las consigo porque cada año
entonces es algo complicado
obviamente estar en control
siempre hablo personalmente en lo mío y
ha sido algo complicado las hormonas por
qué
los niveles de testosterona se me suben
demasiado en los exámenes de sangre me
salen elevados entonces es algo
complicado este tránsito y por eso es
muy importante tener el acompañamiento
de la epe es claro mike y además que eso
él pues lamentablemente va a tener
consecuencias a lo mejor a un largo
plazo en su salud y lo importante es que
pues tenga todas las herramientas
necesarias a la mano cuando las necesite
y no cuando el sistema pues se disponga
hacerlo pero que nos falta entonces a
nosotros como sociedad en general para
dejar también usted lo decía
discriminación incluso entre los médicos
o sea el odio en nuestras diferencias
para respetar la diversidad
yo digo que aquí lo que lo que primero
necesitamos es aprender más del tema
conocer más de las personas trans
conocer que hay personas trans no
binarias que tenemos que diferenciar
entre identidades de género orientación
sexual
expresión de género sexo o sea son
tantas cosas que tenemos que educar a la
gente para que esto ya no sea un tabú y
ya sea una realidad entonces tanto hay
tabú para las personas como para los
especialistas o sea aquí lo que se
necesita es que se haga una ley trans
donde se proteja la integridad de las
personas trabajan donde tengan acceso a
sus citas y aquí en colombia es difícil
una persona que cambie de género digamos
una chica atrás que coloque femenino ir
a sacar una cita de la próstata porque
no se puede porque el sistema se nos
rebota igualmente para los chicos trans
que si se quieren hacer una citología
que no se puede porque tienes una bebé
entonces son tantas trabas en las cuales
necesitamos que ir al estado se
pronuncie ya siendo identificado ya que
ya tenemos la primera célula trans ya
nuestros derechos si no sean tan
vulnerados y ya el acceso a estas
entidades sea sea más amplio y más y más
rápida digamos que mike obviamente este
tema de salud pública en colombia
siempre es demorado para cualquier
persona pero cree que en el caso
particular de las personas trans es más
de discriminación que otra cosa
sí sí porque como yo te decía o sea
lastimosamente si tú no llevas el aval
de psiquiatría no puedes iniciar
hormonas y hay veces hasta los
endocrinos te dicen hasta que no me lo
traiga si no te mando los exámenes
entonces es atrasar el proceso y
obviamente hay muchas personas que lo
inician en particular porque las citas
son devoradas y ya cuando quieren
acceder a las hormonas por la dps
lastimosamente se las quitan porque ya
le afectó el hígado o le ha afectado los
riñones entonces esto es algo que de
verdad se necesita mucho apoyo de la
salud entonces aquí es donde nosotros
estamos diciendo que que necesitamos que
ya haya una entrada más fácil para las
personas trans que las entidades las
diferentes entidades se capaciten sobre
cómo se puede llevar subirnos a eso y
cómo se puede respetar la integridad y
la dignidad de las personas trans y
ojalá así sea y no se requieran años
para que esto pues se ponga en práctica
mike gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa un gran abrazo
igualmente muchísimas gracias a ustedes
que tengan un excelente día